well Reid Hoffman serial entrepreneur
tech investor isn't called the startup
whisperer
of Silicon Valley from PayPal to
LinkedIn to Facebook he's had his hand
in so many of Tech's most successful
companies well Bloomberg West's Emily
Chang sat down with Hoffman in her new
series studio 1.0 and Emily what did you
discover that we didn't know about Reid
Hoffman hey there Betty well studio 1.0
is really an opportunity to go in depth
with the influencers in tech and media
we talked to these guys all the time on
Bloomberg West when they're making news
but we don't talk to them about who they
are how they got there and where they're
going and that's what we did with Reid
Hoffman Betty he's one of the most
decorated guys in tech from PayPal to
LinkedIn he's now a venture capitalist
at Greylock he's an angel and personal
investor in dozens of companies he's on
the board of seven companies and now
he's the author of not one but two books
he's out with a new book next week
called the Alliance it's about
rethinking the relationship between
employer and employee take a listen to
how he describes it the key thing is in
many circumstances companies employers
and employees are lying to each other
because the notion is the modern career
is actually in fact changing where
there's options for shifting companies
for how do you evolve even career tracks
are changing the question is how do you
get that investment in the future and
that entrepreneurial relationship
between the company the employer and the
employee and the short answer is
eyelines and that's an alliance is based
on tours of duty where you set up for a
project that's like three or five years
long and that transforms your career
makes you employable and transforms the
company
so the idea Betty is a job isn't forever
and you know neither party should be
under the impression that it is but it
should be advancing your career in some
way and this isn't a book just for the
Silicon Valley set this is something
that he hopes really every middle middle
manager in America is going to want to
read it's actually a pretty good read
Betty and I found it interesting and you
know I think any manager would find it
interesting and useful to Emily what was
the most surprising thing that you heard
from read so many surprising things I
mean we talked to him
about everything from growing up in
Berkeley to being obsessed with Dungeons
and Dragons but I think one of the most
surprising and interesting parts of the
interview was when he talked about
PayPal the PayPal mafia as they are
known in Silicon Valley and now beyond
you know all of the people who came
together to found and start PayPal was
really a group of a bunch of people who
were all entrepreneurial themselves and
they went on to start companies like
Tesla SpaceX Yammer Yelp LinkedIn all of
these company YouTube all of these
companies founded by members of the
PayPal mafia so I asked him what was
special about the members of that family
the people who started that company he
said all of them really had their own
sort of entrepreneurial spirit and even
though they worked well together at
PayPal they all went on to start their
own things and one of the most
interesting things he said is that they
all still call each other all the time
when he's talking about financial
modeling or needs help with complicated
financial things Reid Hoffman calls
Peter Thiel when he's thinking about big
data and business models with respect to
technology he calls Max Levchin when
he's thinking about you know crazy big
ideas where risk is not a factor he
calls Elon Musk and I thought that that
was that was really fascinating that
indeed the PayPal mafia is very much
still alive and well in Silicon Valley